l'image du français grands mangeurs de
pain et de plus en plus erroné
la consommation ne cesse de baisser elle
a diminué de moitié en 60 ans et
pourtant le pain pourrait redevenir la
base de notre équilibre alimentaire
existe-t-il un pain idéal c'est le thème
de l' enquête menée pour nous par
patricia j'en ai et michel charlot et
michel levasseur qui à l'occasion du
concours de la meilleure baguette qui
vient de se dérouler à paris on y va la
faire est d'importance quinze jurés pour
décerner le grand prix de la baguette de
la ville de paris 120 candidats les pins
sont hâtés déguster renifler cinq
critères doivent être pris en compte
la cuisson le goût la mie l'odeur et
l'aspect deux heures de tests pour
identifier la meilleure baguette une
reconnaissance très importante des
précédents lauréats sont devenus
fournisseurs des palais de la république
le gagnant un boulanger du xiiie
arrondissement quel est son secret les
ingrédients les mêmes que ses
concurrents farine de blé celle au
levure alors le travail à l'ancienne
il n'y a pas de gros secret on laisse
fermenter la panne de façon
guigou et puis on travaille sur couche
on prend son temps pour faire du groupe
c'est à dire combien de temps ça prend
de faire du bon pain
ils sont contrés entre le moment où on
met la farine dans le dans la langue
dans le pétrin il faut compter cinq
heures jusqu'à ce qu'elles semblent il
faut du riz de la fermentation donc et
diversification des farines au goût le
bli suffi pour faire une très bonne
baguette mais son contenu en minéraux
vitamines et fibres et deux à cinq fois
plus faible qu une farine complète ne
s'agit pas d'une bataille entre les
anciens et les nouveaux s'agit pas de
dote d'un retour en arrière au contraire
le il s'agit de deux d'arriver vers un
pain qui seront vraiment de qualité je
pense que les progrès techniques et
scientifiques nous permettront justement
d'aller vers un pain extra le pain blanc
n'est pas encore condamné
mais le pain du 21e siècle pourrait bien
avoir une autre allure la profession
n'est d'ailleurs pas hostile à cette
évolution
il nous faut peut-être apporter des
céréales complémentaires aussi revoir
notre méthode parce que sur le pain
blanc
on sait qu'on est très mécanisée alors
ils sont peut-être revenir au travail à
la main mais on le fait tous déjà sur de
petites productions paysanne ou
parisienne la baguette obéira aux
exigences des consommateurs
les boulangers sont prêts à mettre la
main à la pâte